case three case three is a bit easier
and requires less ruler in your glasses
than um
in case two okay here's what i'm gonna
do just like with case one
the key here is to put a line
the key here is to put a line through
the center i need a diameter
okay so once you put that in
if i connect up this diameter
with the triangle that i've drawn
you'll notice i have a special shape
this is a quadrilateral but it's not
just any quadrilateral right
all four vertices i should label them
it's the original triangle there's the
extra bit a b
c is a second quadrant
all four vertices y on the circumference
of a circle okay
now you need to know this important
property about
cyclic quads okay and to illustrate it
just like with our other um angle and
semicircle proof that they're all equal
to 90
i want you to draw me a little circle
and draw in a cyclic quad
what i'd like you to add on to it is all
its diagonals there are only two
one two now i'm going to do something
very very similar to what i did before
okay but i'll use some colors to help me
you remember the angles standing on the
same
arc like this there we can you see that
right so wherever you see that
you've got equal angles and here i've
got a whole bunch of them
the easiest ones to see are the ones
that are literally standing so
for instance i could call this angle
here alpha
which would mean i have another alpha
here can you see that
same arc can you see it yeah this is
this arc down here is the one they're
standing on
okay but i have other angles that are
doing exactly the same thing
for instance crane your head look at it
upside down
right can you see i also have angles
standing on the same arc here
beta and beta you see it
yeah they're standing on this side
they're both standing on that eye and i
can do this again right
let's see i've got gamma
and gamma those guys just stay on the
same arc
and i can do it one more time
watch can you see it i mean there are
the only angles left right
it's going to be delta and delta okay
now what have i got
what have i got i've now accounted
for every angle in the cyclic quad the
original shape
i drew right the original shape has four
angles because it's a quadrilateral but
because i've divided them all up i now
have eight
so if i add them all up together i've
got two alphas
i've got two beaters i've got two gammas
and i've got two
deltas okay and the angle sum of the
quadrilateral of course is
360. okay
so now if i divide through right
i have alpha plus beta plus gamma
plus delta there are 180 degrees ah
but watch now if you look at where i see
these configurations of angles
for instance because i've conveniently
colored it for you i've got an alpha
and a gamma there and in the opposite
corner
i have a beta and a delta right i've got
all four of these angles
right so therefore these angles these
opposite angles of the cyclic chloride
they should add up to
180 degrees they're supplementary aren't
they and i've got the same thing
happening up here
right there's my alpha delta and there's
my b to gamma
okay so the whole point of that was to
show this is the property you may
remember last year
opposite angles of a cyclic
quadrilateral
are supplementary exactly right now
that's really useful
sorry that's a bit messy it's really
tremendously useful
in this case case three because look i
have a cyclic quad
here's a over here right so if that's a
where's the opposite angle it has a name
b pc right yeah so this is 180
minus a over here right
so far so good now i have an angle in
the semicircle
in that triangle as well right here's
the diameter and here's where i'm at the
circumference so that's 90 degrees
yes and lastly i have the diameter
okay so now in this triangle in
triangle bpc okay
if i look at sine of this angle over
here
right sine of angle b
p c it should be opposite on hypotenuse
right
because unlike here i'm actually on one
of these angles on the other side right
so it's opposite on hypotenuse
a over d yeah
what is bpc we just went to length to
show that it's 180
minus eight but hold on hold on
that's sine right if you have sine of
some angle
and sine of 180 minus the same angle
those two are the same right sine of 180
minus
a is just sine a right
so that's a over d and when you switch
places
you've got the good old sine rule okay
so whether the angle you're interested
in is acute or right angle
or obtuse in every case the reason why
the sine rule works
why all these racial ratios all equal to
each other is because they're all
equal to this diameter that diameter of
the circle
that passes through all three points
okay